countries in the horn of africa are
struggling with extreme drought
world aid organizations warn the regions
on the brink of catastrophe with more
than 20 million people experiencing food
insecurity in the wake of five
consecutive failed rainy seasons
dw's edith kimani visited farmers in
adama ravine at the heart of kenya's
bread basket to see how they're adapting
to multiple challenges
this was supposed to be a bumper harvest
for jonathan kibbett
but things could not have gone worse for
the kenyan farmer
first the rains failed to come in march
then an infestation of army worms
attacked his crop
and most recently a violent storm
flattened his entire harvest
will not be having anything to eat
because if this farm was producing let's
say
18 15 to 18 bucks now i'm
projecting maybe i'll get three to five
bucks
now you see that gap a gap of around 10
bucks
that one will be a serious a serious and
a serious problem
kenya ranks as one of the countries with
the highest food insecurity in the world
as a rain-fed economy the country relies
almost entirely on produce from
small-scale farmers like jonathan who
simply can't keep up we have been using
an ancient mode of doing farming
we have not gotten maybe more
enlightenment or now we can do other
manageable ways of farming
on a neighbouring farm samsung talam
gets to tilling his land
the high cost of fuel has meant he can
no longer afford to hire a tractor
it's a lot of work with little return
he takes me to see this year's harvest
it's not promising
indium
beans these are beans not the ones are
there
just another box there this is the only
one i have harvest right now what is
here
the 65 year old is now at risk of
poverty as even his dairy business is
threatened by the scarce animal feed
the impact of what's happening on the
farms can already be felt in informal
settlements right here in the city the
price of maize flour which is a staple
in the country is now retailing for
close to two dollars but for a
population living in extreme poverty
that can feel like a death sentence
and that was made evident in this viral
video showing a shopper's visceral
reaction at a supermarket to the
increased food prices
on the streets the view is similar
you can't expect someone earning a
dollar a day to buy maize flour for two
dollars children here are going to
school hungry we can't even feed them
breakfast
food security expert anne miner has been
critical of african government's
inability to create crop and diet
diversity her suggestion focus on
climate resilient and nature-driven
farming we need to harness our resources
already we have several huge drums that
have been built but also putting money
in investing in small irrigation
facilities conservation of water
building of water plants would make a
huge difference in terms of food
production in kenya
back in the rift valley jonathan is
already rolling out his next plans
sorghum a more drought resistant crop
with a ready market he's hopeful he'll
bounce back
when the rains come
if they come edith uh tell me about it
just just how bad is the situation where
you are
it's more obvious in the northeastern
part of the country which has a more
arid and semi-arid climate and there a
food security steering in the steering
group in the country estimates that 3.7
million people are facing starvation in
the cities where i am or in the
breadbasket regions like where i made
that report from it's less obvious but
the climate shocks are definitely
affecting the harvest as we saw in the
report but also a serious pest issue we
were being told in 2020 that kenya is
losing as much maize to pests as it is
as it is importing so there's a huge
problem uh with food supplies not to
mention the global commodity shops that
we're seeing of course because of the
war in ukraine
is there a reason heat resilient
varieties can't be used across the whole
country
the first reason is economic as a small
scale farmer it makes more sense for me
to grow maize because i can then offload
it quite easily to the people around me
if i'm using something like sogam or
millet which is less of a staple in the
country it means i have to have a
contract with say a brewery and that's
less uh
then of course there's access uh the
people who do want to use these draft
resistance seeds don't have access to
them because they'll be available in the
country as of 2023 but only in an
experimental capacity and this is what
we got from the ministry and finally
there's the health concern particularly
biodiversity and biosafety groups here
in the country are asking why would we
want to invest in genetically modified
crops when in the west
the move is more organic
edith camani thank you very much for
your reporting
you